choses à élucider dans toutesste
poursuit du côté de la SQ.
- Merci.
L'horreur a de nouveau frappé
à Zapore nuit, une pluie
de missiles s'est abattue
quartiers résidentiels
faisant au moins une vingtaine
de morts et des dizaines
c'est un bilan provisoire.
Comme vous le voyez,les recherc.
Je joins notre envoyée spéciale
en Ukraine, Marie-Eve Bédard.
de vouloir recevoir se venger
après avoir encaissé de lourds
revers, des pertes importantes,
notamment avec cette attaque
hier contre le pont de Crimée?
- Une attaque n'a toujours pas
été officiellement revendiquée
par l'Ukraine, mais on craignait
une réaction forte, une réaction
vive de
tardé. Au cours de la nuit,
vous l'avez dit, une pluie
de missiles qui s'est abattue
de gens habitaient, un édifice
d'appartements assez élevé,
mais dans des quartiers
résidentiels aussi où de toutes
en briques ont été complètement
soufflées par cett
d'explosions. Les recherches
ont commencé dès cette nuit,
dès les premières explosions.
Pour les habitants, ça a été
une nuit ont survécu à l'attaque
ont cherché à se mettre à l'abri
mais cherchent pour beaucoup
toujours des leurs. Le président
Volodymyà réagir. Sur les réseax
sociaux, il a fait une
déclaration et je vous le cite.
Il a dit :
Et pour les gens donc qui
attendent toujours proches, ce t
des moments interminables
d'angoisse. Je vous propose
d'écouter une femme qui a passé
cette nuit... qui a été
des explosions, et qui a vite pu
sortir de l'édifice.
- Bon alors, Marie-Eve,
on en parlait il y a un momea ée
sur le pont de Crimée, hier,eh e
l'Ukraine d'en être responsablen
officielle de la Russie etdu pre
qui rencontrait le comité
d'enquête qui se plosion
sur le pont qui relie
la Russie à la Crimée.
Il a accusé donc les services
ukrainiennes d'un attentat
qu'il a qualifié lui aussi
de terroriste. Selurré
d'explosifs qui aurait fait
exploser ensuite ce train
qui contenait des citernes
avec du pétrole. M
la circulation est déjà rouverte
partiellement sur le pont.
la Russie promet de fairepayer .
Rih, en Ukraine. Merci.
- Au rev